-Performing her new single,
"Lighthouse,"
please welcome Paris Jackson!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Ooh ooh ooh ooh ooh ♪
♪ Ah ♪
♪ Ooh ooh ooh ooh ooh ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ♪
♪♪
-♪ I'm the flask
in your pocket ♪
♪ On a rainy day ♪
♪♪
♪ She's the one
that you share it with ♪
♪ On the train ♪
♪♪
♪ You ♪
♪ Burn your throat ♪
♪♪
♪ Intoxicated on what could
have been our love ♪
-♪ Ah ah, ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ah, ah ah ♪
-♪ I know those few drops
won't satiate ♪
♪♪
♪ And I know I'm not
what fills your veins ♪
♪♪
♪ You ♪
♪ Made it to the coast ♪
♪ With your notes on my ghost
and everything it's made of ♪
♪♪
♪ I can feel the lights go low ♪
♪ But I don't wanna let go now ♪
♪ Maybe if I turn around,
you'll see me ♪
♪ And what you used to be ♪
♪ Your wave keeps crashing
in a changeless sea ♪
♪♪
♪ And I can't help but feel
it's drowning me ♪
♪♪
♪ No, I ♪
♪ Can't breathe ♪
♪♪
♪ The oil's burnt
in the lighthouse ♪
♪ My ship wrecked
on your teeth ♪
♪♪
♪ I can feel the lights go low ♪
♪ But I don't wanna let go now ♪
♪ Maybe if I turn around,
you'll see me ♪
♪♪
♪ I can feel the lights go low ♪
♪ But I don't wanna let go now ♪
♪ Maybe if I turn around,
you'll see me ♪
♪ And what you used to be ♪
-♪ Ah ah, ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ah, ah ah ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]